hi everybody this is jonathan trance and
i'm here at the lovely studio at the st.
Louis Chess Club and I have another
tactical challenge for you so when you
see the position on your screen go ahead
and pause your video and we'll see if
you can solve it in this position it's
white to move are you ready for the
solution well I hope you didn't get
tricked into playing Bishop takes f7 and
it's true even after King takes Bishop
rook takes Queen pawn takes rook White
does have a pretty pleasant position
here because all of his pieces are a
little bit better than blacks but you
have an even better move so if you got
tricked by this solution go ahead and
try to solve it again pause your video
and see if you can find the right answer
the correct answer is matin - based on
the fact that black has a weak back rank
so here after the move rook to d8 blacks
only move is to block with the night and
after rook takes Knight it's checkmate I
hope you enjoyed this puzzle
congratulations to everybody out there
that was able to get this one right and
if you want to see more of this hit
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
thank you for watching